a woman named rosemary has a nightmare
in which she finds herself in bed with
the devil
and a pregnancy shrouded in mystery will
make her distrust everyone around her
today on cinema recap i'll show you
rosemary's baby
the film begins with a happily married
couple who is looking for an apartment
to rent he is an actor who has appeared
in some plays and commercials and she is
rosemary's happy wife a man shows them
the whole house while he tells them that
the previous owner died
although she did not die inside the
apartment but rather in a hospital we
see that someone moved a wardrobe to
cover a closet door
they think it was the previous owner but
they don't know why she would block that
closet
since there were useful things inside
rosemary loves the apartment and asks
her husband to get it but then a friend
of theirs tells them stories of
witchcraft that happened right there
many years ago
even so they decide to move and begin to
settle into their new home
they find out they have elderly
neighbors
they have to eat dinner on the floor and
then they make love
the house remodel continues and we see
the husband in a yamaha motorcycle
commercial
and rosemary does her first laundry in
the basement
there she meets a girl who claims to be
a guest of her elderly neighbors they
gave her a necklace that smells bad but
it's supposed to bring luck
the girl speaks wonders of the elderly
marriage
later rosemary and her husband overhear
the elders arguing on the other side of
the wall
and soon after they hear them chanting
some kind
of spooky right
then one night where the young couple
were returning home they see the police
outside the building
the girl rosemary met at the basement
jumped out of a seventh floor window the
elders arrived shortly after and
although they do not believe that the
girl has done such a thing the police
showed them the body and the letter that
the girl wrote before jumping the elders
say that the girl had no family
but rosemary interrupts them and says
that she did
since she had told her about her brother
in the navy
she also says that what happened seems
impossible to her
since the girl did not seem depressed or
anything
that night rosemary has nightmares about
a screaming mother and the next morning
she receives a visit from the neighbor
who's very kind and
loves all the changes she's made to the
apartment
rosemary tells her that she and her
husband are planning to have three
children the older one invites her and
her husband to dinner at her house
and rosemary accepts
when coming home from work a guy the
husband says he didn't get a big role
that he auditioned for
rosemary tells him about dinner and they
both agree to go
although they say they don't want to be
close friends with the old couple
the neighbors are very kind and friendly
hosts
they have a very pleasant talk about
their past
and guys work as an actor
and at the end of the night
they say goodbye with huge smiles
at home guy tells rosemary that the old
man can help him in his career so he'll
continue to visit him
while rosemary talks about how strange
it was that it seemed then neighbors had
removed pictures from the walls
the next day rosemary receives a visit
from the old neighbor lady and a friend
of hers
we see her a little upset to receive
them and then the old woman gives her a
necklace similar to the one that the
girl who jumped out the window was
wearing
she keeps the necklace and her husband
receives the news that the actor had got
the job that he auditioned for
became blind overnight
so guy was offered the role the next day
rosemary talks to her friend saying that
her husband has been very absent from
home
however when he gets home he apologizes
for it and tells her that he wants to
start creating family with her they
celebrate their decision to have a child
with a romantic dinner
the neighbor interrupts them by bringing
them a dessert although rosemary says it
tastes a bit strange
her husband insists it's a gift and she
should eat it
rosemary eats some more of it ends up
throwing out the rest
soon after rosemary begins to feel dizzy
so her husband takes her to bed
once there she begins to have happy
dreams
while her husband removes her clothes to
make her feel more comfortable
the dreams begin to turn gloomy
separating from her husband
being inside the sistine chapel and
having a lot of strange visions until
she ends up on a bed in a dark room with
many old people
naked surrounding her
these elders sing a right and even the
husband is among them
rosemary's legs are bound and a strange
creature mounts on top of her
then rosemary says that this is no
longer a dream that it is happening in
real life
but then she loses herself again in
hallucinations
asking a priest for forgiveness for what
she's doing
the next morning she wakes up with some
scratches on her back although her
husband convinces her that they are due
to having sex during the night days go
by and rosemary tells her husband that
he's been acting really weird lately
like he doesn't even want to see her
even though he says that's not true
shortly after rosemary receives the news
that she's pregnant although the medical
staff ask her to return to the hospital
for further tests on her health
the couple decides that the baby to come
is the perfect reason to put their
fights aside and start their happiness
new
and guy says he has to break the news to
the neighbors when the neighbors come to
celebrate they recommend a good doctor
to follow up the pregnancy
and rosemary agrees to change her
current doctor
at night rosemary gets restless and
decides to wear the old woman's gift
then her new doctor tells her not to pay
attention to books or advice from
friends regarding her pregnancy and to
take special smoothies instead of
vitamins which her neighbor knows how to
prepare
rosemary gets a haircut and says she's
in pain but the doctor says it's normal
also we see that she barely cooks the
meat she eats
when her friend visits her he warns her
that she is losing weight instead of
gaining it like any pregnant woman
but she says that the doctor says that a
small would lose weight before you start
to gain it
their talk is interrupted by the
neighbor who insists the doctor's
recommendations are correct
then the friend loses one of his gloves
before leaving the apartment
at night rosemary receives a call from
her friend who wants to talk about
something very serious with her the next
day
however the friend does not show up for
the date
and rosemary later finds out that he
fell ill at night and slipped into a
coma
rosemary's discomfort increases we see
her eating raw chicken and when she
realizes that something is not right she
stops taking the neighbor's smoothies
and even starts crying with her friends
during a baby shower
they advise her to see another doctor
and when she tells her husband he gets
angry
saying that the doctor they have is the
best in town and in the middle of the
discussion rosemary is happy to feel
that her son is already kicking
they put the discussion of the doctors
aside and start buying things to receive
the baby
then they find out that the friend who's
in a coma passed away
and at the funeral they are told that
before his death the friend left a book
for her
we see that rosemary returned to eating
everything the neighbor gives her and
when she opens the book
she sees that it's one about witchcraft
in which there are marked words and
pages
using letter tiles rosemary discovers
that the name of a sorcerer in the book
has the same letters as the name of her
neighbor
so he might be the son of the sorcerer
although her husband tells her that it's
a crazy idea
rosemary tells him horrible things about
witchcraft that she read in the book
tells him that she doesn't want to see
the neighbors anymore and that she wants
to move out
she says that she will do whatever it
takes to keep her child safe
however her husband and the doctor tell
her that those are just stories in her
head
also they convince her not to move since
her neighbor is supposedly sick and will
die soon so he's going on a trip with
his wife and therefore there's no reason
to move
later rosemary finds out that her
husband threw away the witchcraft book
which makes her suspect that even he is
an accomplice in what they've been doing
with her
so she goes out
throws the necklace the old woman gave
her away
and buys another book of witchcraft then
she speaks to the actor who went blind
asking questions until she finds out
that her husband exchanged an object
with him before he went blind
so she assumes that guy performed
witchcraft to get his role
rosemary takes her suitcase and goes to
seek help from her doctor
but when she talks to her secretary she
realizes that he has a necklace just
like hers
so he is also involved in the whole
witchcraft thing
she leaves and calls the doctor
recommended by her friends who agrees to
see her
rosemary shows him all the evidence
she's collected saying their neighbors
are witches and her husband allied with
them in exchange for fame as an actor
she tells him that they've been casting
a spell on her through the food because
they want to do witchcraft with her baby
and she is surprised to see that the
doctor believes her
he tells her that he does not believe in
witchcraft but he does believe that
there may be crazy people in the world
who believe in it and practice it
then he tells her to rest and she obeys
having a nice dream with her baby in her
arms however when she wakes up she sees
the doctor brought her other doctor and
her husband her old doctor tells her not
to make a scene or else she'll be
admitted to a psychiatric hospital
while her husband tells her that no one
is going to hurt her unable to do
anything
rosemary allows them to take her back to
her apartment however she creates a
distraction to get on the elevator by
herself and locks herself in the
apartment
there she calls a friend and leaves a
message for to call back
at the same time we see that somehow
two people got into the apartment
when rosemary turns around she sees that
the intruders open the front door so the
doctor entered and he injects her with a
sedative to put her to sleep
screaming rosemary apologizes to her
baby for not being able to defend him
better when she wakes up her husband
tells her that the baby was born and is
fine
then it's a boy
she relaxes but when she wakes up again
she sees a stranger who calls the doctor
and her husband and they inform her that
the baby has died her husband tries to
tell her that they can make another baby
later
but rosemary says she doesn't believe
them and calls them witches
they put her back to sleep and as the
days go by rosemary pretends to be fine
her husband tells her that his career is
taking off rosemary asked him to show
her his shoulders since according to the
books all sorcerers remark that that
part of the body
her husband shows it to her and she sees
that he has nothing
however rosemary begins to hear a baby
crying although a lady tells her that
she does not hear anything
they give her pills but rosemary doesn't
take them
then her husband tells her that they
have new neighbors who have a baby and
that's why she's been hearing baby
noises
however rosemary doubts everything again
when she sees the do not want to waste
the milk that she produces
one night rosemary removes tables from
the closet that was covered by the
wardrobe at the beginning of the film
since it connects with the neighbor's
apartment
finding out that that's how the
intruders could enter the apartment then
armed with a knife rosemary enters the
neighboring apartment where she finds a
pile of dark paintings hanging as well
as a large group of people having tea
around a crib with a black veil
her husband and the neighbors who were
supposed to be traveling are there too
rosemary walks to the crib being watched
by everyone and goes crazy when she sees
her baby
saying that his eyes are very strange
then the old sorcerer says that the baby
inherited his father's eyes
in other words the eyes the devil
everyone begins to pray for satan
although rosemary does not want to
believe that she had the son of the
devil
people come to leave gifts for the baby
the husband tries to tell her about the
wealth they will get
but she spits in his face then hearing
the baby cry rosemary reaches out to
calm him down the old sorcerer says that
it's fine
that she can approach the baby if she
wants because after all
she is his mother
rosemary does so and this time she
finally finds peace of mind when she
sees that her baby has stopped crying
thanks to her presence
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best horror movies
thanks for watching